Yeah, that's a fake sound. We've all heard those
trucks and sports cars roar past us with deafening
engine noises. And whether you're into it or
find it super annoying, like I do. The truth is,
this sound is not necessary. It is not like
a byproduct of a really powerful engine. Car
companies are designing the engines to be
louder on purpose with no power benefits,
and sometimes they're literally faking it.
Pumping fake engine noises through speakers.
Why? Why? Turns out the car executives are
afraid that customers will hear quieter engines
and think that their car isn't as powerful.
They're literally making them sound worse to
appear better to someone. Capitalism is weird,
y’all, I'm telling you, this is weird. This is
concerning. Now there is one case in which making
cars artificially louder may actually have some
benefit and is actually required by federal law.
And it has to do with the quietest cars of all:
electric cars. They’re too quiet! These cars
are so quiet that you can't hear them coming.
And that's actually potentially dangerous because
if you can’t hear a car coming, like the car will
hit you. I mean. Yeah, okay. That makes sense.
I guess. Whatever. But do we really need this?